Film Courage: How do you create an awesome horror
protagonist? Peter Dukes, Writer/Director: How do you create an awesome
horror protagonist, antagonist or
protagonist? Film Courage: Both. I said
protagonist but let's do both. Peter: I think it
just comes down to for me in particular
what horror films inspired you the most
and for me I have certain ones that were
important to me or influenced me certain
horror directors that influenced me more
so than others certain life experiences
I think certain real-life fears I think
for me I take the DNA contained with all
of them I try to put it into a memorable
but memorable character I think I don't
really want to do a character that we've
seen a million times before if I can
help it I want to make someone where you
truly don't know what's gonna happen
next or you feel the stakes or
heightened one of the tropes and one of
the consequences of of following the
similar structure I went to writing
screenplays it's the audience kind of by
this point knows where it's going most
of the time they've seen everything it's
hard to really fool them so whenever I'm
putting together a story and whenever
I'm coming up with characters whether
it's a protagonist and certainly an
antagonist is I want to do someone who
if it's a horror piece someone who
scares me and you know where that comes
from just depends on what the story is
but I want him to be memorable I want
them to be unique and to stand out I
think it'd be fun if one day if I ever
did that type of story I made one of
those guys she becomes like Connick why
not have it be the next Pennywise you
know you've seen these these fun posters
they'll do where all the bad guys are in
a movie theater I want one of my guys to
be there you know I'll put them in that
group someone that kind of just stands
out just like the filmmaker themself has
to find a way to stand out from the
crowd I'd love to come up with a
character that you know people remember
and kind of stands the test of time I
think that's the goal well I mean do you
think that
the person has to be real likable is to
stake carry and I know I use that a lot
but I found Carrie to be a very likable
character I know
sure maybe people do but and I found
that the the antagonist in the film to
be very unlikable yeah I I think as
always each stories organic and the
characters have to be true to what the
story is I am attracted to I think good
guys that aren't squeaky clean and bad
guys that aren't vaudeville bed twirling
their moustaches I like to muddy it up I
like gray characters I think that's
something that people can relate to a
lot if you see a bad guy that at times I
wouldn't say you empathize with but you
can understand a little bit definitely
not a James Bond villain this is someone
who is more relatable and in that sense
can be more scary
it could be someone you know or someone
that you can believe running into some
day and the same thing with a good guy
I'm far more interested in a protagonist
who I can relate to and most people you
know they're not perfect
they've got flaws and maybe they've had
some things in the past that they regret
I wouldn't go as far as to say they have
you know big sins hiding in their closet
but you know they have imperfections and
maybe they've done things they're not
proud of I think that makes for a far
more interesting character now again
since I've mentioned James Bond for
doing James Bond people when James Bond
villain they want they want a little bit
of the vaudeville in there and that's
fine and for Carrie you'd mentioned I mean
Cary she had to be likable she I think
and they got Sissy Spacek was amazing in
it you kind of had to feel she was
literally a real girl in high school who
was kind of a loner in the outsider and
that's the way that character had to
work and her mother was terrifying it
she had to be you know and I I don't
think making that mother and pathetic
would have worked in that story so the
kind of great character I'm talking
about you know comes down to the
appropriate story that it's used for so
but for me though those are the kind of
characters that attract me good or bad
and
generally when I'm coming up with a
story I look for ways to really kind of
flesh them out in that manner and then
you had the Betty Buckley character who
to some could have seen like the bad guy
but she was you know very altruistic to
carry yeah and was almost like prodding
her and like this tough love and I
thought that was a great thing because
she didn't have that she had all these
different forces yeah listen I think
whether you're making someone who's a
little bit muddy or they're just full on
bed or full-on good I think the goal
should be to make these characters you
know three-dimensional you should almost
be able to feel their motivations just
by watching their face or their actions
or what they're doing in this scene not
necessarily only with dialog and you
know from any writing standpoint that's
what you're always aiming for no one
really ever I think sets out to write
what they call it kind of a cardboard
you know or the carbon copy
you know characters someone who feels
very two or one-dimensional and very
flat and we're kind of saying that you
expect them to say no writer sets out to
do that on purpose I think but you know
it's a tricky thing to really flesh
characters out on the page you know I'm
sure when they wrote you know carry they
didn't have Sissy Spacek bare to flesh
you down they didn't have her there to
bring it to life someone originally had
to bring that character to life on the
page it's a hard thing to do and I think
it's something that writers must demand
themselves to really aspire to and work
on I'm really trying to get theirs as
best they can and am i there yet I don't
know I try to be and going forward as
always as an everything I do always
trying to push it to the next level just
get a little bit better hone your craft
and keep going further and further I
think I'll do that till I die I don't
think I don't know any filmmaker who
feel or writer who feels they've finally
got it they finally got it you know at
some point I think they're all even the
best of the best I imagine are still
honing their craft well with the
Nightmare on Elm Street series or you
know it seemed like the the protagonist
would change but the antagonist was
always the same and so am I am I correct
in that it's been yeah
first film for the well there were a few
are there many yeah so I'm just trying
to remember correctly so it seemed like
the the protagonist always changed but
the antagonist was always the same yeah
you need more people to be bad to I guess so
yeah okay all right and and then you put
in the music - so we're like this fun
sort of almost party feel to a lot of it
but then you knew something franchises
are tricky and I give people a lot of
credit for trying to take him on this is
had you mention Nightmare on Elm Street
because yeah I remember was taking that
one I've watched about a year ago the
original film it's a scary movie it's a
really scary movie and I had forgotten
how popular was it went on to span five
or six films or whatever was but it
became so popular and this happens a lot
of horror franchises that the original
antagonist it becomes part of the you
know pop culture zeitgeist he eventually
became the comic relief in his own
movies whenever he Freddy was in the
scene he was given all the funny lines
very straight and then they took a break
for a few years and they made the new
nightmare where they made him scary
again but they needed that break he was
like a different character still Freddy
Krueger but he was he looked a little
different he's very dark or whatever
it's uh it's it yeah but that's
Hollywood writing a franchise it's just
another complication I'm sure as a
writer to come in you just kind of have
to go the flow and make it work but I do
remember that it do you remember there
being a drastic change along the you
know life in that storyline and you're
right it was one antagonist always one
antagonist and the protagonists would
come and go and survive or not not
survive you know yeah I enjoyed it
you